hello and welcome to this video wim
lendy who is that no further information
so Carol pretty decent rating for W I am
wim is really really really wide range
of playing strength from quite high to
very low the stylist sometimes also
given form some achievements in junior
chairs and sometimes those some persons
are really low rated but 2248 is very
very okay of course so let's go it's a
gambit line here that I'm playing and I
have to admit that I don't know much
about it it's a bit of a gamble taking
on between that looks risky yeah do I
have to go there I think after c3 c3 did
not work
yeah interesting so she goes back to the
aid what now him luke t one could be a
move
yeah maybe rookie one so how does that I
would have said I'm fooled is that
something him she probably castles short
after after kunal's I'm doing with g45
him as I said it's a bit of a gamble I
really don't know if this is any good
yeah it looks if you ask me that looks
fishy for Wyatt but yeah it's what it is
it's a it's an aggressive line and maybe
not one hundred percent correct and what
now though 95 no well it doesn't really
do much
yeah to come check on shore of f6 maybe
black is going for gasoline long it's
not out of the picture castling short
looks a tad risky after same maybe 95
that that's possible that twinge III
take sticks and fairly active there on
the D file
maybe Quincy seven trying to know ok so
here I'm going to do three taking this
temple
[Music]
yeah that's that's kind of what I
expected I wonder some c4 here maybe
it's it's interesting that's interesting
I probably don't have enough but five
now she's just each is just about quick
enough see if I Brooke t5 ok I have to
do this 96 maybe
[Music]
and something like that I have to try
the tea i can play before and Bishop see
797 that looks dangerous King TX rock d7
Andrew t7 there's a pretty big threat
anyway so Bishop takes g3 it does not go
check so check Kim g6 okay i will take
first and then see if i check their King
g6
Chet have to start with the check that
is pretty much clear I want to go here
into g4 to get get to check the King
under more pressure check so that should
be ok here right for draw five
[Music]
could be dead risky
see aid might come down after 45 so this
is something that she has to attend to
somehow cheerful and that's very
dangerous she cannot what's chat really
that works that looks very dangerous
time warning check check check
check check check check
that's a draw cannot do much else check
check Graham Arthur on tough game tough
game so let's see that was probably a
bit fishy I mean I know that this is the
line that is played but no details so
the engine gives like a slight advantage
but it's a very low very low calculation
depth she was probably not good twin g3
that was my original idea but I felt
that she can just castle chat which
doesn't seem to be the case why exactly
ok Knight takes bishop h7 and cream
cakes there's also be sufficiently okay
i can play c3 and take ok so Queen g3 is
correct because castling is not possible
and then this is kind of interesting if
she cannot Castle him and the move that
she has to play is not ideal at least
something like g6 or something we should
eat seven is given by the engine the
chat is so interesting actually this is
not yeah ok so here we get something I
would taking first is better ah and this
move no did not see a rock be three that
looks very strong actually did i get b 7
this position is grade no did not see it
i saw that i have a pretty decent
compensation hear it that is actually
not that great yea year before this is
helpful check
check age 4 immediately check so this is
not enough age five she has to that was
h5 made so ticks ticks ok I have rupiah
seven but I felt that this is dangerous
but probably it is just this is probably
just leading to draw she didn't think
about that why she could sorry that's
made yeah she could have done that and
now with this move yeah probably i don't
think i should lose this check and now
go back yeah that's probably a draw
check your and here we have the check
check check check check more straw if
she tries to escape this age 78 made
some it was a draw ok thanks for
watching